via hyperspace is a really cool project
what we've been looking at is
investigating virtual reality in future
aircraft and the reason we talk about
future aircraft is at the beginning of
this project in 2011 virtual reality was
still not you know people didn't think
about virtual reality anymore even
though it's been around for like over
thirty years and virtual reality wasn't
necessarily in favor we were looking at
virtual reality for future aircraft for
passenger comfort because we thought we
had a great idea we thought if you could
use virtual reality to extend the space
in an aircraft or you could use it to
make you feel comfortable so believe
that you're more comfortable then that
would be a really really like cool thing
to do so I am definitely an absolute
sci-fi nut I'm not going to say I'm a
Trekkie but I've been known to be called
a Trekkie
and absolutely the whole idea of the
holodeck flying in space everything
about that is has led me to be the
scientist that I have been my brain is
telling me I know that there is nothing
here but visually because I can see all
these people around that I do want to
try and get out like this I've always
been absolutely fascinated by the fact
that you could enter into this computer
world and be anywhere you want to be
industry very much used virtual reality
where you couldn't have people in a real
environment so you can understand why
the space industry used virtual reality
because obviously you can't send loads
and loads of people up in space so much
of the research has been about creating
accuracy in a virtual environment can we
make the space in reality and virtual
environments map accurately but now it's
interesting for you the voice and the
avatar is co-located so we said well
okay what happens if we don't want it to
map accurately what if we want to use
the space research to actually make this
face bigger so can we use virtual
environments to make the space bigger so
in a aircraft when you're in a really
confined space can we use virtual
environment
to extend that space so this is where
the research has been for the last three
years and comfort has been a really
really complicated thing because people
have so many different ideas and
opinions of what makes them comfortable
so there are problems there are always
be problems when you look at technology
the biggest problem that virtual reality
has interestingly is to do with the
stereo so one of the problems with
actually having stereo vision so in a
head mounted display for example you
have to have two different images to
your eye in order to make the stereo
happen and some people experience this
already when they're looking at 3d
movies where you're you've got the
glasses you're trying to work out and
make the stereo happen now some people
in the head-mounted display with the
stereo and with motion can actually
experience sickness now sickness is a
real issue because obviously we wouldn't
want loads of people wearing head ranted
displays and feeling sick we also don't
want loads of people wearing head
mounted displays for for a long time
getting eyestrain so actually we're a
human factors research group part of the
reason we started in virtual reality was
to actually look at the technology we
were a beat test site way back in time
to look at the issues related with
virtual reality and the long-term use of
these technologies which is why when we
were doing the project via hyperspace we
had psychologists and neuroscientists
all trying to understand comfort but
that was very much to do comfort with
this the technology we were using as
well as comfort in terms of like what
people were seeing so you know there are
lots of problems that always are with
technology and you know science
shouldn't be afraid of actually looking
at them and so I shouldn't be afraid of
saying them sickness is a problem that
has to be studied and has to be overcome
yes dance still and close your eyes so
it's been a real challenge but really
interesting to see what you can do in
terms of changing people's environments
to increase their comfort one approach
has involved using head mounted displays
so head mounted displays block the whole
world out and only allow you to use
whatever virtual environment we're
showing so that's great because you can
put people in an extended space you can
put them in a comfortable space you can
put them anywhere you want to and we've
been using head mounted displays to look
at how you would embody yourself in that
space what if you believed that the
avatar that you are in that virtual
environment is you can we make you feel
more comfortable the other approach
we've been looking at is actually
putting displays in surfaces around you
so we have a couple of demonstrators one
is a cabin environment where we've put
loads of displays on the back of seats
on the floor on the sides and we've
looked at how you can extend that space
by making all the seats invisible or
taking the plane away and to see whether
people they are comfortable with being
in an invisible plane and do they feel
like they're in an extended space and
the other system we're looking at is a
multi-user multiviewer system so it's
actually about shared spaces that's
using really really large scale displays
but it's using cameras in order to beam
other people into that space so that you
can have a shared experience so we're
creating positive illusions and what we
mean by this is we are using virtual
environments to enable passengers to see
themselves in a much more comfortable
position than maybe they are in the real
world we're also using virtual
environments to extend the actual
environment so in their cabin space or
if they really want to be outside of the
plane to put them in an alternative
reality and alternative space which is
much more comfortable and also to allow
them to interact with other people so
people they want to interact with
because you can imagine on a plane you
might be with other people who you don't
know who you may
not want to know and you might want to
interact with people from home and so
they can be brought into your shared
space maybe you want to read your
children a bedtime story and you're on
the plane you can still physically or
virtually be in the same place you can
beamed into their bedroom or they can
come onto the plane and you can still be
that person and read the story
you